We get support from UC Davis, a globally ranked university, working to solve the world's most pressing problems in food, energy, health, education, and the environment. UC Davis researchers collaborate and innovate in California and around the globe to find transformational solutions. It's all part of the university's mission to promote quality of life for all living things. Find out more at 21stCentury.ucdavis.edu. This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. The five basic principles of flag design. According to the North American Vexelological Association, Vexelological.
我们得到了戴维斯加利福尼亚大学的支持，这是一所世界排名的大学，致力于解决世界上最紧迫的食物、能源、健康、教育和环境问题。UC戴维斯的研究人员在加州及全球各地合作并创新，以寻找变革性的解决方案。这全是该大学旨在促进所有生物生活质量的使命的一部分。请访问 21stCentury.ucdavis.edu 了解更多信息。这里是“百分之九十九隐形”。我是罗曼·马尔斯。旗帜设计的五个基本原则。根据北美旗帜学协会，旗帜学。
And Vexelology is the study of flags, sexual law, that makes us so weird. Number one, keep it simple. The flag should be so simple that a child can draw it from memory. Before I moved to Chicago in 2005, I didn't even know cities had their own flags. Most larger cities have flags. Well, I didn't know that. That's Ted K, by the way. Hello. Flag expert.
旗帜学是对旗帜的研究，旗帜学，这让我们显得如此古怪。第一，保持简单。旗帜应该足够简单，以至于一个孩子可以凭记忆画出来。2005年我搬到芝加哥之前，我甚至不知道城市有自己的旗帜。大多数较大的城市都有旗帜。嗯，我不知道这一点。顺便说一下，那是泰德·K。你好。旗帜专家。
Totally awesome guy. I'm the editor of a scholarly journal on flags called Raven, a journal of exolology. And that first city flag I discovered in Chicago is a beaut, a white field, two light blue horizontal stripes and four six pointed red stars across the middle. Number two. The blue stripes represent the water, the lake, and the rivers. Use meaningful symbolism. The red stars represent significant events
绝对超级棒的家伙。我是旗帜学学术期刊《渡鸦》的编辑，该期刊专门研究旗帜学。我在芝加哥发现的第一面城市旗帜真是一件艺术品：白色的底色，两条浅蓝色的水平条纹，中间有四颗六角红星。第二。蓝色的条纹代表水、湖泊和河流。使用有意义的象征。红星代表重要的事件
in Chicago's history. The design of the Chicago flag has complete buy-in with an entire cross-section of the city. It's everywhere. Every municipal building flies the flag. Every 20-year-olds messenger bag and hoodie has one. It's a distinct symbol of Chicago's pride. When a police officer fire- firefighter dies in Chicago,
在芝加哥历史上。芝加哥旗帜的设计得到了该市各个阶层的完全认同。它无处不在。每个市政建筑都悬挂这面旗帜。每个20岁年轻人的信使包和连帽衫上都有一个。它是芝加哥骄傲的鲜明象征。当芝加哥的警察或消防员牺牲时，
it's not a United States flag on the casket. It's the city of Chicago flag. That's how deeply it's gotten into the city's civic imagery. And it isn't just that people love Chicago and therefore love the flag. I also think that people love Chicago more because the flag is so cool. A positive feedback loop there between great symbolism and civic pride. So when I moved back to San Francisco in 2008, I researched its flag because I'd never seen it before in the previous eight years I lived here.
棺材上盖的不是美国国旗。而是芝加哥市旗。这就是它如何深入该市的公民形象中。不仅是因为人们热爱芝加哥因此热爱这面旗帜。我还认为人们更热爱芝加哥，因为这面旗帜太酷了。伟大的象征意义和公民自豪感之间存在着一个正反馈循环。因此，当我2008年搬回旧金山时，我研究了它的旗帜，因为在我在这里居住的前八年里，我从未见过它。
And I found it, I'm sorry to say, sadly, lacking. Well, let me start at the top. Number one. Keeping it simple. So simple that a child can draw it from memory. It's a relatively complex flag. The main component of the San Francisco flag is a phoenix representing our rising
我发现它，抱歉地说，令人遗憾地有所欠缺。好吧，让我从顶部开始。第一。保持简单。简单到孩子能凭记忆画出来。这是一面相对复杂的旗帜。旧金山旗帜的核心部分是一只凤凰，代表着我们在1850年代大火之后
from the ashes after the great fires of the 1850s. A powerful symbol for San Francisco. I still don't really dig the phoenix. Design wise, it has too many details and too many colors, and it doesn't really work at a distance. But having deep meaning puts that element in the plus column. Behind the large Phoenix, the background is mainly white, but the flag also has a substantial gold border around it, which is a very attractive design element. It does look pretty good, but here come the big no-nose in flag design. No lettering or seals. Never use writing of any kind. Underneath the Phoenix, there's
浴火重生。这对旧金山来说是一个强大的象征。我仍然不太喜欢这只凤凰。从设计上讲，它有太多的细节和太多的颜色，而且在远处看起来效果不佳。但由于拥有深刻的意义，该元素可以算作加分项。在大凤凰的背后，背景主要是白色，但旗帜周围也有一道宽阔的金边，这是一个非常有吸引力的设计元素。它看起来确实相当不错，但旗帜设计中的重大禁忌来了。没有文字或徽章。绝对不要使用任何文字。在凤凰下方，有一个
a motto on a ribbon that translates to gold and peace, iron and war. Plus, and this is the big problem, it's a San Francisco across the bottom. If you need to write the name of what you're representing on your flag, your symbolism has failed. United States flag doesn't say USA across the front, but the good news is this name thing might not be completely our fault. A city flag in a state that has its own name on the state flag would end to echo that. Yep, the California Bear Flag says California Republic on it. So maybe we can blame this all on our capital city Sacramento,
缎带上的座右铭，翻译过来是“黄金与和平，铁与战争”。另外，这也是最大的问题，底部写着“旧金山”。如果需要在旗帜上写下你所代表的事物的名称，说明你的象征手法失败了。美国国旗正面并没有写着“美国”，但好消息是，这个名称的问题可能不完全是我们的错。在一个在其州旗上有自己名称的州里，城市旗帜往往会呼应这一点。是的，加利福尼亚的熊旗上写着“加利福尼亚共和国”。所以也许我们可以把这一切归咎于我们的首府萨克拉门托，
which is awesome because I love blaming Sacramento for things. I like to say that in every bad flag there's a good flag trying to get out. Well, the way to make San Francisco's flag a good flag would be to take the model off because you can't read that at a distance. I would take the name off and the border might even be made thicker, so it's more of a part of the flag. And I would just simply take the Phoenix and make it a great big element in the middle of the flag. The current Phoenix has got to go. I would simplify or stylize the Phoenix, depict a big wide-winged bird coming out of flame, emphasize the flame.
这太棒了，因为我喜欢把事情归咎于萨克拉门托。我常说，每一面糟糕的旗帜背后，都有一面优秀的好旗帜正试图破茧而出。好吧，让旧金山旗帜成为好旗帜的方法是去掉座右铭，因为你在远处根本看不清。我会去掉名字，甚至可以把边框加粗，让它更像是旗帜的一部分。我只会简单地把凤凰放大，让它成为旗帜中间巨大的核心元素。现在的凤凰必须走。我会简化或风格化这只凤凰，描绘一隻展翅高飞的大鸟从火焰中冲出，强调火焰。
So next time you find yourself with a vexalologist, I am never going to say that word right. A flag expert? Park yourself there. You're in for a good time. By the North American vexalological association. See, it's not just me. It's not just me. 99% Invisible is produced by me Roman Mars with support from Lunar. It's a just me. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
所以下次你发现自己和一位旗帜学家在一起时——我永远也说不对这个词。一位旗帜专家？在那里驻足吧。你会有段美好的时光。由北美旗帜学协会提供。看，不只是我。不只是我。“百分之九十九隐形”由我罗曼·马尔斯制作，并得到了 Lunar 的支持。这只有我。本集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。